[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Michel midoro bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde on commence avec cette
information à l'approche de l'hiver la
nuit tombe plus tôt et les cambrioleurs
en profitent les chiffres dans le
département sont à la hausse la fin
d'année est une période propice au
cambriolage il est estimé que 27 % des
intrusions dans les imé ont lieu à cette
période selon nos confrère du Parisien
lundi 20 novembre au soir pas moins de 8
effractions ce sont produites à Manent
laajolie mais aussi saint-jeanl et
rambouillé un phénomène qui s'accélère
depuis 2 ans en 2022 plus de 4600
effractions ont été recensé par le
ministère de l'intérieur ce qui place
les ivelines largement en tête des
départements franciliens l'Est ivelinois
est la zone la plus touchée et la
gendarmerie donne des conseils Michel la
gendarmerie appelle à la prudence pour
dissuader les voleurs à le conseil de
laisser les volets ferm lorsque vous
rentrez tard et de ranger les objets de
valeur à l'intérieur si vous vous
absentez dans la soirée pensez à les une
lumière allumée pour simuler une
présence et à activer l'alarme s'il y en
a une bien sûr on poursuit ces
informations avec un changement
encourageant dans les ielines le tri des
emballages ménagers et des papiers
progressent d'après nos confrères des
nouvelles avec 2 kg de plus par franc
cilien le tri des déchets ménagés est en
légère hausse c'est ce qu'a annoncé
Citeo une entreprise à mission créée par
les secteur de la grande consommation et
distribution une tendance visible aussi
dans les Ines avec 49 kg par hab an
c'est 1,5 % de plus qu'en 2021 mais le
département fait quand même moins bien
que la moyenne nationale qui est de 72
kg et on termine avec du sport Michel ce
weekend promet une belle rencontre
sportif au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en Eveline c'est la 9e
édition du Grand Prix de Vézy sur la
piste environ 120 cyclistes venus de
toute la France s'affronteront chaque
année l'équipe cycliste véisi 78
organise cet événement pour le plus
grand plaisir des sportifs et des
supporters plusieurs épreuves sont
programmées vitesse kirine scratch ou
encore course au point un événement qui
se déroule de 10h à 18h depuis sa
création en 2015 des athlètes de très
haut niveau y ont participé Taki Taki
Marie divine Kame championne du Monde
2022 François Pervis SEP fois champion
du monde encore les médaillés de Tokyo
Sébastien Vigier Florian gringbaau Ryan
Hal et Benjamin Thomas du beau monde du
très beau monde merci beaucoup Michel
midoro pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
setweet news